>> PRESIDENT BIDEN GETTING MORE
DESPERATE AFTER FAILING TO
GASLIGHT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
INTO THINKING THAT PUTIN IS
BEHIND HIGHER GAS PRICES.
NOW HE IS RESORTING TO TEENAGE
TIKTOK STARS TO PUSH HIS PRICE
HIKE PROPAGANDA.
>> I THE OPPORTUNITY TO ASK THE
WHITE HOUSE LIKE GUEST ON THE
STREET IS $7 AND HERE'S WHAT
THEY SAID.
RUSSIA IS ONE OF TOP THREE
PRODUCERS IN OIL AND THERE
NUMBER ONE RESOURCE.
THAT WAS BEFORE STARTING THIS
HORRIFIC FIGHT BETWEEN UKRAINE
AND RUSSIA, NOBODY WANTS TO WORK
WITH HIM OR INTERNATIONAL TRADE.
>> TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY PP
TO BRIDGE ISN'T EVEN FOCUSED ON
THE SURGING PRICES.
>> GAS PRICES ARE FAMOUSLY
SOMETHING THAT IS LARGELY
OUTSIDE OF THE DIRECT CONTROL OF
ANY POLITICAL FIGURE.
>> WHY DO YOU LIVE?
>> PETE SPINNING SO HARD.
GREG, ARE YOU NOW CONVINCED
EVERYTHING IS OKAY AFTER
WATCHING THAT TIKTOK PROPAGANDA?
SPEAK I WAS SITTING AROUND GOING
COULD THERE BE A MOVE THAT IS
ANY MORE UNSERIOUS THAN SENDING
KAMALA TO POLAND, WHAT COULD IT
BE?
WHY NOT USE AN APP FAVORED BY
12-YEAR-OLDS THAT IS CREATED BY
CHINA THAT IS INFILTRATED AND
MANGLED SO MANY ADOLESCENT
BRAINS.
THAT IS FUNNY.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT THOSE.
TIKTOK MIGHT BE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE CYBER WARFARE IN
HISTORY.
BECAUSE IT IS IN EVERY HOUSE, IT
CAUSES KIDS TO DO REALLY BAD
STUFF TO EACH OTHER AND TO
OTHERS.
SOMETIMES IT IS SELF-MUTILATION.
IT IS BASICALLY DELIVERING TO
OUR KID'S BRAINS.
IN CHINA, THESE TIKTOK TO
EDUCATE YOUR KIDS.
THEY HAVE RULES.
YET WE ARE POLLUTING OURSELVES.
BUT AGAIN, IT SHOWS YOU HOW
UNSERIOUS WE ARE ABOUT ENDING
THIS WAR.
BORIS JOHNSON, THE GUYS WHOSE
HAIR LOOKED LIKE YOU DUMPED A
BOWL OF LINGUINE ON IT, HE IS ON
TOP OF THE ENERGY QUESTION.
HE IS MEETING WITH AVOIDABLE
PEOPLE, THE GAS PEOPLE BECAUSE
HE IS NOT CONCERNED WITH
PLEASING TWENTYSOMETHINGS WHO GO
BY THEY AND THEM.
>> WE ARE CONCERNED WITH
TEENAGERS ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
>> DOES THIS SAY THAT BIDEN
DOESN'T HAVE ANY REAL FIXES?
JUST WORRIED ABOUT P.R.?
>> JEN PSAKI WAS ASKED ABOUT IT
AGAIN TODAY AT THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS BRIEFING AND HER ANSWER IS
ALWAYS THE THIS IS A PRIORITY
FOR HIM TO ADDRESS.
THESE PRICE HIKES FOR THE
AVERAGE AMERICAN CONSUMER, IT IS
PAINFUL, THEY ACKNOWLEDGE AND
SAY THAT ALL OPTIONS ARE ON THE
TABLE.
WE STILL DON'T KNOW THOSE
OPTIONS ARE.
I ASKED PEOPLE IN THE GAS ENTRY
WHAT COULD BE DONE TO INCREASE
AND INCENTIVIZE MORE DRILLING.
OBVIOUSLY MORE OIL PRODUCTION TO
BRING THOSE GAS PRICES DOWN.
IF YOU WERE TO THINK ABOUT IT
REALLY REASONABLE TO HEAR FROM
THIS ADMINISTRATION, THE OIL AND
GAS INDUSTRY OF THE
AMERICAN PETROLEUM INSTITUTE
JUST SEND US A FRIENDLIER
MESSAGE IS, THAT YOU ARE NOT OUT
TO DEMONIZE OIL COMPANIES.
THEY WANT TO TAX THE OIL
COMPANIES MORE.
IN A MOMENT WHERE WE ACTUALLY
NEED THEM.
WE NEED MORE OIL PRODUCTION
AIRED AND BY THE WAY, THE
MESSAGE TO THE TIKTOK VIEWER OUT
THERE IS GREEN ENERGY IN A
MOMENT WHERE 65% OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE LIVING PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK.
THEY ARE TELLING YOU ON TIKTOK
TO GO BY AND EV.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE AVERAGE GAS PS
OF AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE WHICH
MARKED $60,000.
>> AND THEY JUST RAISE THE
PRICES BECAUSE OF ALL THE SUPPLY
CHAIN PRICES.
GERALDO, ARE YOU NOW ON BOARD
WITH THE PUTIN PRICE HIKE AFTER
WATCHING THAT YOUNG LADY TELL
YOU ALL THE TALKING POINTS?
>> THAT DEFINITELY PUT ME OVER
THE TOP.
I CAN SEE THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
BLEW IT WHEN HE CRUSHED DOMESTIC
OIL PRODUCTION.
THAT WAS A STRATEGIC ERROR,
REGARDLESS OF THE TIKTOK-YOU --
BUT
THIS IS ALSO TRUE.
EXXON, CHEVRON, BP, AND SHALL
ARE ALL ENJOYING
ENJOYING THE HIGHEST PROFITS.
>> WHAT IS YOUR POINT?
>> THE OIL COMPANIES ARE REAPING
RECORD PROFITS.
SOME OF THIS COULD BE HANDED TO
THE CONSUMERS RATHER --
>> YOU WANT --
>> WHY DON'T WE LOOK TO THEM AND
SAY --
>> WHY DOESN'T THE GOVERNMENT
CUT THE GAS TAX?
SPEAK OF THE GAS TAX IS THE ONLY
THING THAT KEEPS THE HIGHWAYS
TOGETHER.
MANY POLITICIANS OF VARIOUS
STRIPES --
>> WE GET BACK TO THE QUESTION.
ARE YOU SUGGESTING THAT THOSE
COMPANIES ARE ENGAGING IN
ILLEGAL ACTIVITIES BY FALSELY
PROPPING UP GAS PRICES?
BECAUSE IF YOU ARE, THEY SHOULD
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
IF THEY ARE, EVIDENCE SHOULD BE
SHOULD BE PROVIDED.
>> I'M SUGGESTING THE OIL
COMPANIES ARE REAPING WAY MORE
PROFITS AND THE WINDFALL PROFITS
TAX IS MUCH MORE VILE TO ME THAN
GETTING RID OF --
>> BUT YOU OWN STOCK AND ENERGY
COMPANIES PITTSBURGH I DO.
SPEAK OF THE ONLY PEOPLE MAKING
WINDFALL PROFITS ARE RUSSIA AND
VENEZUELA IS ABOUT TO MAKE SOME.
BUT LET ME JUST COMMENT ON THE
TIKTOK FIRST.
I NEVER THOUGHT ANYTHING COULD
BE MORE RIDICULOUS THAN WHEN
KAMALA HARRIS HAD THOSE YOUNG
CHILD ACTORS HELP HER IN THAT
SPACE VIDEO.
REMEMBER, WE COULD SEE WITH YOUR
OWN EYES THE MOON.
REMEMBER THAT ONE?
I ALSO WANT TO TALK ABOUT A
SEGMENT OF OUR POPULATION THAT
WE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT.
AND THAT IS THE SENIOR CITIZEN.
SO THE ALTERNATIVE TO THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, WE ARE NOT
GOING TO DRILL HERE, NOT GOING
TO LOOSEN UP ON THE REGULATIONS.
WE'LL GO TO VENEZUELA.
WE WON'T BEG THE SAUDIS ALTHOUGH
THEY WANT TO OUR CALL.
AND WE WANT TO ELECTRIC CARS
SENIOR CITIZENS DRIVE CARS WITH
INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINES.
THEY CANNOT AFFORD AN ELECTRIC
CAR.
AND UNLESS THE GOVERNMENT WANTS
TO GIVE THEM A VOUCHER FOR AN
ELECTRIC CAR WITH THEIR NEXT
SOCIAL SECURITY CHECK, THEY ARE
THE ONES WHO ARE LOST IN ALL OF
THIS.
THEY ARE ON A FIXED INCOME.
THEY CANNOT AFFORD ANYTHING.
THEY CAN'T EVEN THINK ABOUT
ELECTRIC VEHICLE.
SO WHILE WE ARE GOING -- WHY
DON'T WE CONSIDER OUR PARENTS,
OUR GRANDPARENTS, THE PEOPLE WHO
FOUGHT THE WARS, WHO BUILT THE
STREETS.
THEY ARE BEING CRUSHED WHILE
THIS PRESIDENT ONLY CARES ABOUT
TIKTOK.
>> CAN I GET THIS ONE LAST
POINT, BECAUSE THE WHITE HOUSE
AND DEMOCRATS LIKE TO TALK --
NOT DRILLING.
GOT THE PERMITS ISSUED.
BUT THEN CREATE A FRIENDLIER
ENVIRONMENT FOR THOSE ENERGY
COMPANIES TO DRILL.
IF THEY DRAW, GUESS WHAT THEY
HAVE TO DO?
SPEND THOSE PROFITS.
>> I AM ALL FOR IT.
I DON'T SEE WHY JUST BECAUSE YOU
ARE IN FAVOR OF A GREEN FUTURE
YOU CAN'T DO PRACTICAL -- I AM A
PRAGMATIC IDEALIST.
TALK TO CHEVRON, EXXON, BP AND
SHELL, AND SAY YOU ARE DOING
GREAT.
NOW DO ME A FAVOR.
>> CAPITALIST SOCIETY.
LEAVE THEM ALONE.
UNLESS THEY ARE PROFITEERIN